So let us start
with our example.
Suppose that you go
to a supermarket,
and start observing
customers arriving
and leaving from a
given checkout counter.
Assume that there
are two customers
in the queue when you arrive.
For simplicity, assume also the
customers come one at a time,
that there is a single queue,
and that the customer in front
of the queue is the one
getting served by the clerk.
So what events of interest
could happen then?
A new customer could join the
queue, which is an arrival.
Or the customer
currently being served
is done, and leaves-- departure.
Or both events could happen.
Now for making our
model more precise,
we need to specify the processes
of the customer arrivals
and departures.
And for that, let's use
some simple discrete time
stochastic processes, which
we have introduced before.
So as usual, we first divide
time into discrete time steps,
say in seconds.
Here n equals 0 would correspond
to the time when you arrived.
For arrivals, let's assume
that customers arrive according
to a Bernoulli process
with parameter p.
And at that time,
steps here, there
is an arrival, perhaps
this customer here.
At 6, there is another customer.
So during each time
interval, independently
of what happened in the
past, with probability p
a new customer arrives.
And with probability 1
minus p, no one comes.
It may be useful to think
about the following imaginary
experiment.
Imagine that during
each time interval,
nature independently
flips a biased coin, which
has a probability p of resulting
in Heads, and 1 minus p
in Tails.
And whenever Heads
is the result,
then a new customer
joins the queue.
So in our example here, here
you obtain Tails, Heads, Tails,
Tails, Tails, Heads,
Tails, et cetera.
From the lecture on
Bernoulli process,
remember that this implies
that the time duration-- that
means the number of
time steps between two
consecutive arrivals-- follows
a geometric random variable
with parameter p.
So here in our example,
that time duration of 4
is the result of a geometric
random variable with parameter
p.
So again, once in the queue,
customers wait their turn
until they start being
served by the clerk.
And typically, when a
customer starts to check out,
the number of times
steps it takes
to go through the entire process
will depend on many factors,
such as the total number
of items selected,
the speed or the mood of the
clerk, and so on, so forth.
We will model this
variation by assuming
that the service
duration of any customer
is the outcome of
a random variable.
In particular, we will
assume that the number
of time steps it takes for
any customer to check out
is a geometric random variable
with a constant parameter q.
That is, the same q
for each customer.
So you might have
a departure here.
That's correspond to
that customer here.
And another departure at
time step 6 correspond
to that customer.
It may be useful,
again, to think
about another
imaginary experiment
to represent this
service duration.
Imagine the following.
At the time a
customer in the queue
becomes the one to be
served, that customer
starts flipping a
biased coin, which
has a probability q
of resulting in Heads.
And it does so independently
during each successive time
steps, until Heads appear
for the first time, which
then indicates that the
checkout service is done,
and that the customer can leave.
So here in our example, you
arrive at that time here.
And this customer
was being served.
And during that time
step, the customer
flips a coin resulting in
Tails, Tails, Tails, Heads.
That customer now leaves.
The next customer
start being served.
At that time, flips
a coin-- Tails,
Heads-- then that
customer leaves again.
Finally, we will also assume
that the processes modeling
these arrivals and departures
are independent of each other.
Now let us go back to
our made up experiment,
and assume that you
have arrived at 6:45 PM.
Consider the following question.
What is the probability that
you observe a customer leaving
the checkout counter
during the first time step?
In our example, since there
were at least one customer
in the queue, that
probability is then simply q.
However, if that queue had
been empty when you arrive,
then that probability
would have been 0.
Another question, would the
queue be empty at 6:50 PM?
That means 5 minutes later.
Well, it's hard to tell.
If the initial
length of the queue
had been huge when
you arrive at 6:45 PM,
then the probability that it
will be empty 5 minutes later
would be very
small, much smaller
than the probability in that
case, with two customers
initially, or in that case
with an initial empty queue.
From these questions
and answers,
it looks like knowing
the number of customers
in the queue at
any point in time
not only provides a good
description of the system
at that time, but it
does seem to capture
the critical information we need
in order to answer questions
about the future
evolution of the system.
So let us define the
state of our system
as the number of customers in
the queue at each time step n,
and see what we can do.
So here, in our example,
initially we had 2 customers.
Then, time step 1,
still 2 customers.
Time step 2, we have 1 arrival.
So we have 3 customers.
Time step 3 still 3.
4, 3 minus 1.
We have a departure, equals 2.
So 5 will still be 2.
Time step 6, we have an
arrival and a departure.
So we have 2.
And so on and so forth.
Assume now that there is limited
space in the supermarket,
and that no more than 10
customers can be in the queue
at any point in time.
We can then give a
graphical representation
of all possible states for
our system, as follows.
A system can be 11
different states,
from an empty queue
with no customer,
to a system at full
capacity with 10 customers.
Let us now describe some
possible transitions
between these states,
from one step to the next.
Suppose first that the
system is in state 2,
and that one new customer
arrives and no one leaves.
So you will transition
from 2 to 3.
And this is what happened in
this example, from time step 1
to time step 2.
Suppose now that
you are in state 3,
and that a customer
leaves, and no one arrives.
Then you will
transition to state 2,
like what happened
between time step 3 and 4.
What else?
Well, you could also be in a
given state at one time step,
and stay in this same
state at the next step.
How?
It can happen in two ways.
If there are no arrivals and
no departure in the next step,
and that was what happened
between time step 4 to 5
here, 4 to 5.
Or there is 1 arrival
and 1 departure,
like what happened
between time step 5 and 6.
A graphical representation
of all possible one-step
transitions can be done with
the help of arcs, such as here.
In order to complete
our model, we
need to indicate the
probabilities associated
with these transitions.
So again, assume that
you're currently in state 2,
with 2 customers in the queue.
The probability of
next going to state 3
here, with 1 more
customer in the queue
is simply a
probability of having
1 arrival and no departures.
On the other hand,
the probability
of being here, and going
in transition next here,
correspond to 1
departure and no arrival.
Finally, the system
can stay in state 2,
like that, when there is
1 arrival and 1 departure,
or no arrivals
and no departures.
These transition
probabilities would be similar
if the current
state were 1, 3, 9.
For the two extreme states,
the transition probabilities
are a bit different.
If you are in state
0, the queue is empty,
and you can go to state 1
with 1 additional customer,
with a probability p.
Or there is no new
customer coming,
and you stay in state 0.
And if the queue is
at maximum capacity,
either you stay at
maximum capacity
if there is no service, or
you go down to 9 customers
in a queue if you
have a departure.
So one important fact.
When you are in a given
state, for example state 2,
and you look at all possible
transitions, could go to 3,
could go to 1,
could remain in 2.
If you sum all
the probabilities,
p times 1 minus q
plus q times 1 minus p
plus this total probability
here, pq plus 1 minus p times
1 minus q, you will get
a total probability of 1.
Similarly, if you look
at this probability here,
they sum to 1.
And these
probabilities sum to 1.
It's simply says that from
one time step to the next,
if you consider all possible
transition probabilities,
they all have to sum to 1.
So in conclusion, this so-called
transition probability graph,
which is this
representation here,
provides a complete
representation
of a discrete time
finite state Markov
chain model of our simple
supermarket checkout counter
example.